at least 100 giant cargo ships are
floating in limbo off the southern
california coast carrying billions of
dollars worth of goods they can't unload
it's the most visible sign of today's
global supply chain crisis
we have never seen
the volume of containers we are seeing
today we are busier than ever we are at
full capacity
but the warehouses are also fully
subscribed the ports of l.a and long
beach are the largest in the u.s
handling about 40 percent to one half of
all imports mostly from china but due to
covetera online spending sprees by
american consumers staffing shortages
and sheer lack of storage capacity
compared to the volume of shipping the
ports are jammed even after ramping up
to 24 7 operations the pandemic had the
effect
of impacting every segment of the supply
chain all at the same time
on top of that the pandemic triggered
heightened demand for goods overseas
from u.s consumers
u.s consumers are buying goods at a
historic base u.s president joe biden
has allocated government funding and is
urging more coastal ports warehouses
trucking companies and other links in
the supply chain to work 24 7 to solve
the problem we have to take action now
together with our partners in the
private sector
to reduce the backlogs that we're facing
the winter holiday gift giving season is
fast approaching so what's on board all
of these ships stuck out in the harbor
waiting to unload well there's clothes
computers furniture electronics and of
great importance to parents and
grandparents everywhere
toys
isaac larian sells toys lots and lots of
very popular toys kids can't get enough
of this can't get it his mga
entertainment company includes gotta
have it items like lol surprise bratz
and many others so this none or not
surprise little little lily cats a kitty
cat camper
we have research it's going to be a
hardest story this year hottest story
this year
over 70 percent of the demand is sitting
on
boats and contain containers and china
factory
they won't make it for christmas and i'm
talking about the supply chain logistics
nightmare the snarled supply chain is
slowing down global economic growth and
boosting inflation now it might mean a
lot of disappointed kids i love children
more than i love toys my advice to
consumers who is watching this
please go and shop early experts predict
the crunch will persist well into next
year rob reynolds al jazeera long beach
california